>>> TONIGHT MILITARY STRATEGISTS
ARE TRYI TO GET INSIDE
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S HEAAND
UNDERSTAND RUSSIA'S DECISION TO
FIRE POWERFUL HYPERSONIC
MISSILES INTO UKRAINE.
THESE MISSILES ARE VERY FAST AND
THEY'RE VERY DANGEROUS.
>> RIGHT.
WE'VE BEEN REPORTING ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF HYPERSONIC
MISSILES FOR MONTHS BUT THIS IS
THE FIRST KNOWN USE OF THESE
MISSILES IN COMBAT.
WE HAVE NEW INFORMATION ON THE
CAPABILITIES OF THESE MISSIONS
USED BY THE RUSSIANS AND THE
POSSIBLE REASONS THEY WANT THEM.
>> Reporter: VLADIMIR PUTIN
UNVEILS A NEW WEAPON IN HIS
ARSENAL.
OFFICIALS CONFIRMING THAT RUSSIA
LAUNCHED HYPERSONIC MISSILES.
THE FIRST EVER USED IN COMBAT.
THE WORD MEANS DAGGER, STRUCK
AWARE HOUSE IN UKRAINE.
THE U.S. TRACKED THE LAUNCHES IN
REAL-TIME.
>> IT IS A GOOD OPPORTUNITY TO
TEST AND IT A SIGNAL TO NATO, TO
POLAND AND OTHER COUNTRIES THAT
THEY HAVE THIS AND TO KIND OF
KEEP THEIR DISTANCE.
>> Reporter: EXPERTS SAY WHAT
MAKES THE HYPERSONIC MISSILE SO
DANGEROUS, IT CAN FLY AT FIVE
TIMES THE SPEED OF FAST OR
GREATER AND IS MORE MANEUVERABLE
IN FLIGHT THAN MISSILES.
>> IT USES GPS COORDINATES TO
HONE IN ON A TARGET.
IT CAN ALSO BE DIRECTED BY A
CONTROLLER TO SPECIFIC TARGETS
AND IT CAN CHANGE COURSE IN THE
MIDDLE OF ITS TRAJECTORY.
IT CAN FOLLOW THE NAP OF THE
EARTH.
IT CAN GO RIGHT DOWN ON THE
GROUND WHERE BASICALLY IT EVADES
RADAR COVERAGE.
>> Reporter: A SENIOR U.S.
DEFENSE OFFICIAL TELLS CNN,
PUTIN'S DEPLOYMENT TO HIT THAT
AMMUNITION WAREHOUSE IS A BIT OF
A HEAD SCRATCHER.
WHY WOULD YOU NEED A HYPERSONIC
MISSILE FIRED FROM NOT THAT FAR
AWAY TO HIT A BUILDING.
LLOYD AUSTIN ALSO WONDERED THAT
ALOUD IN AN INTERVIEW AS HE DOWN
PLAYED THE USE OF THE WEAPON.
>> I DON'T THINK THIS IN AND OF
ITSELF WOULD BE A GAME CHANGER.
IT QUESTIONS WHY HE DID THIS.
IS HE RUNNING LOW ON MUNITIONS?
DOES HE LACK COMPLETE CONFIDENCE
IN THE ABILITY OF HIS TROOPS TO
REESTABLISH MOMENTUM?
>> Reporter: MILITARY ANALYSTS
SAY --
>> WHEN IT IS LAUNCHED, IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO INTERCEPT THIS
MISSION.
>> WHY?
>> WE HAVE NO TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
CAN DO IT.
THE DEVELOPMENTS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT FROM A MISSILE
DEFENSE PERSPECTIVE ARE WAY
BEHIND THE DEVELOPMENT.
THESE HYPERSONIC MISSILES.
>> Reporter: ONE EXPERT SAYS
PUTIN COULD DEPLOY THEM AGAIN IN
UKRAINE AND THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY THE RUSSIANS COULD
MISUSE THE WEAPON.
>> WE'VE ALREADY SEEN SOME
RUSSIAN DRONES STRAY OFF INTO
NATO TERRITORY.
YOU COULD HAVE CRUISE MISSILES
STRAY OFF AS THEY HAVE IN THE
PAST INTO IRAN WHEN RUSSIA HAS
FIRED THESE IN THE PAST.
SO WHETHER IT ISHEIM SONIC OR
SUB SONIC, THERE IS THE
POTENTIAL FOR MISCAL CHAGS.
SOMETHING GOING WRONG.
>> Reporter: JUST MOMENTS AG